if I want to run a commercial on
television I got to pay if I want to run
an ad in a newspaper I gotta pay if I
want to get an ad in a radio station I
got to pay if I want a billboard out
there I got to pay if I want to make a
piece of content and post it on YouTube
or Tick Tock or Instagram I don't pay
anything and all these people are like
oh these platforms are keeping too much
of the money from the creators [__]
they're giving you free distribution
unheard of in the history of time that's
why they're keeping the economics it's
free so what would I tell everybody if
you don't have access to money start
making content on the internet for free
build up attention and awareness and
watch how people start coming at you all
of the capital that I have had access to
in my life was not based on how I grew
up where I grew up who I grew up with it
was based on that I understood that
attention is the most valuable capital
in the world I understood that social
networks were free attention